salut nous sommes en pleine semaine
spéciale micro-expressions alors
certains d'entre vous sont déjà en train
d'écrire dans les commentaires que ce
t-shirt à une faute d'orthographe ce
n'est pas une faute d'orthographe c'est
une référence un ancien fait divers vous
laisse vous recherchez un petit peu si
jamais vous connaissez pas ce fait
divers c'est en rapport avec omar m'a
tuer n'oubliez pas que dans la
description de cette vidéo il ya une
plaie 10 qui regroupe toutes les vidéos
sur le micro expressions de cette
semaine est la première que j'avais
faite sur ce sujet il ya également un
lien faut je respire de temps en temps
vers le livre de paul ekman qui est la
base de tout le travail actuel sur les
micro-expressions et aujourd'hui on
parle de la 5ème micro-expressions à
savoir la peur je vous parlerai
également d'un site internet pour
s'entraîner génériques
avoir peur ou être un petit peu angoissé
c'est une émotion très courante
nous sommes souvent soumis au stress et
la proche d'un danger déclenché cette
micro expressions alors les dangers tel
qu'on l'entend basiquement mais
également d'autres qui sont moins
évidents ça peut être la réponse à une
question qu'on nous a posés et à
laquelle on se sent contraint de
répondre des choses qui nous gênent les
muscles rentrer en jeu sont les muscle
orbiculaire c'est à dire les paupières
supérieures qui se soulève la pupille
qui se rétractent la bouche qui s'ouvre
légèrement et qui peut tirer vers la
droite ou vers la gauche dans les
généralités c'est pas forcément muscles
du visage mais on se raidit ossements
position d' attaque donc on contracte
nos muscles et enfin les sourcils qui se
lève et qui se rapproche vers le bas je
vous rappelle que c'est la colère et le
dégoût et enfin tous ces signes soit
accompagné d'une action qui le fait
d'inspirer on inspire durant la micro
expressions de peur parce que le corps
de chercher de l'oxygène en fait il
serait dit va chercher de l'oxygène la
meilleure défense étant l'attaqué
le corps se prépare aussi à attaquer et
j'ai donc confié et j'ai donc continué
d'où ce déclenchement d'adrénaline quand
on a peur il ya plein de situations où
le fait de détecter une motion de peur
chez quelqu'un vous permettra de
comprendre ce qu'il ressent vraiment
c'est un peu la micro expressions
négligé des mentalistes et pourtant de
mon point de vue elle est vraiment
essentiel donc je vous recommande de la
beauce et c'est bien la beauce est vrai
comme on bosse les micro-expressions
petit blâme
vous êtes nombreux depuis deux jours à
me demander comment vous pouvez
travailler ça en ligne si possible alors
j'ai creusé j'ai essayé plein de sites
internet depuis deux jours il y en a
beaucoup
la plupart d'entre eux sont payants
malheureusement il ya aussi des
formations en ligne qui sont ultra cher
aussi vous rappelle quand même que ces
vidéos là que je vous fais elles sont
gratuites à la limite vous pouvez payer
d'un petit like et ça coûte pas bien
cher non plus et vous vous pouvez vous
entraîner rien qu'en regardant la télé
plutôt des émissions genre des talk
shows des débats ou des choses comme ça
bon j'ai quand même trouvé un site qui
s'appelle émotions ninja je vous mettrai
le lien dans la description il est
plutôt bien fait c'est payant mais il ya
un entraînement sur dix photos qui est
gratuit au départ
donc vous pouvez vous le faire plusieurs
fois il ya aussi évidemment les
excellents logiciels qui sont
disponibles sur le site de paul ekman je
vous mettrai aussi le lien dans la
description c'est payant c'est pas donné
néanmoins ce sont les meilleurs que je
connaisse il ya jusqu'au 15 novembre
j'ai vu sur le site sur la page que je
vous mettrais il ya un code de réduction
c'est je crois que c'était 20 % de
réduction c'est jusqu'au 15 novembre
il ya plein de possibilités moi je vous
recommande juste de prendre le faith
plus combo si vraiment vous voulez
acheter quelque chose prenez juste le
faith plus combo s'est largement
suffisante à donne déjà des très solides
bases au cours de cette semaine vous est
proposé quand vous conversez avec
quelqu'un de vous concentrer sur des
points clés du visage et de le regarder
un peu du coin de l'oeil
et quand ils bougeront durant un quart
de seconde vous serez plus attentifs et
vous allez pouvoir détecter facilement
les micro-expressions parce qu'avant
d'analysé il faut détecter et c'est
aussi le but de cette série alors pour
continuer en rajoutant la peur à tout le
package qu'on se fait progressivement
depuis lundi prenez conscience sur le
visage de l'autre en permanence garder à
l'esprit le fait de regarder les yeux
l'écart qui ment et à partir
d'aujourd'hui la rétractation de la
pupille les paupières supérieures et les
petites rides autour des yeux pour le
pour le regard rigueur pour la joie les
lèvres les sourcils en entier le nez ici
et ici
le menton et les joues et ça y est on
est vraiment sur le visage en entier
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
nouvelle vidéo du mental blog petit
menthe à l'eau que vous êtes
il nous reste plus que deux micro
expressions avoirs à savoir le mépris et
la tristesse j'ai vu également dans les
commentaires que vous me demandez les
émotions de séduction où les émotions du
bonheur ce genre de choses ce ne sont
pas des micro-expressions cette semaine
on voit les cette micro expressions
majeures ce que vous me demandez ce ne
sont pas des micro-expressions donc
d'abord on va terminer les
micro-expressions n'oubliez pas
également de vous abonner à la chaîne du
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31
décembre rendez vous demain à 11 heures
parce qu'on sera samedi demain et oui
donc 11 heures ciao